on va passer à vue de Russie avec Elena
Volochine c'est tout de
suite et bienvenue dans vue de Russie le
magazine hebdomadaire qui analyse la
propagande de Vladimir Poutine sur fond
de guerre en Ukraine avec comme chaque
semaine Elena Volochine bonsoir Elena
bonsoir Stéphanie cette semaine vous
allez nous parler d'une émission
spécifique qui s'appelle antiake et
c'est une émission à la télévision russe
une émission qui sous prétexte de lutter
contre la désinformation justifie la
guerre de Vladimir Poutine en Ukraine
oui mais d'abord un mot de ce qu'on n
pas vu de Russie hier ce bombardement
sur un village ukrainien de Grosa dans
le District de coupiansque la Région de
kkov au nord de l'Ukraine a fait au
moins 51 morts dont un enfant pas de
cible militaire à priori à proximité la
frappe a atteint un magasin et un café
où une soixantaine de personnes étaient
rassemblées pour un repas de deuil c'est
la frappe la plus meurtrière dans la
région depuis le début de la guerre
totale contre l'Ukraine lancée par
Vladimir Poutine le 24 février 2022 2
pas un mot n'a été dit ou écrit hier par
les agences de presse et les journaux
télévisés russes sur cette attaque seuls
les médias russes indépendants qui ont
dû quitter la Russie à cause de la
censure imposée par l'État russes en non
parlé jamais les médias autorisés en
Russie ne mentionnne le fait que les
frappes russes font des victimes civiles
cela fait partie du système par lequel
l'étar russe désinforme ses citoyens sur
cette guerre et qu' cette guerre qui ne
dit d'ailleurs pas son nom en Russie et
en parallèle de cette censure la Russie
accuse à l'inverse ses ennemis de
désinformation oui on en parlait au
début c'est l'objet donc de cette
émission quotidienne de 30 minutes sur
la première chaîne de télévision russe
PvE canal elle s'appelle antifake son
but annoncé est de distinguer la vérité
du mensonge alors que je cite le site de
l'émission l'Occident fait pression sur
la Russie avec une haine bestiale le
présentateur Alexandre SM et ses invités
en plateau il passe donc en revue de
prétendus fake de médias ukrainiens et
occidentaux regardez l'ouverture de
cette émission c'était lundi
dernier Hiroshima la première
Constitution et les bordures ou les
trottoirs si l'on préfère tout ça ce
sont des fakes du centre des opérations
informationnelles et psychologiques que
nous allons aujourd'hui décortiquer dans
notre programme alors on ne comprend pas
encore à ce stade sur quoi va porter
l'émission maison retient de ce propos
qu'elle va décortiquer de prétendus fake
du centre des opérations informelles et
psychologique qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
centre c'est une unité au sein des
forces d'opération spécial de l'armée
ukrainienne en charge de la guerre de
l'information et le propos dans cet
extrait c'est de dire que les
soit-disant fake qu'on va analyser au
cours de cette émission et bien ils
auraient été propagés par ce centre sauf
que le premier exemple ne tient pas du
tout la route il s'agit d'Ursula
vanonder derlen la présidente de la
Commission européenne qui le 20
septembre a évoqué le bombardement à
l'arme atomique par les Américains sur
la ville japonaise de Hiroshima le 9 mai
45 elle s'adressait au Premier ministre
japonais lors d'une remise de prix à New
York
écoutez nombre de vos proches sont morts
lorsque la bombe atomique a rasé
Hiroshima vous avez grandi avec les
récits des survivants vous avez voulu
que nous entendions ces histoires que
nous fassions face au passé pour
apprendre sur le futur la Russie menace
aujourd'hui de nouveau d'user l'arme
nucléaire c'est abject c'est dangereux
et avec l'ombre d'Hiroshima c'est
impardonnable il suffisait d'ommettre
qui a largué les bombes et à la fin de
dire que la Russie a de nouveau de
nouveau oui de nouveau l'intention
d'utiliser l'ARM
expliquez-nous alors l'émission antifque
prétend que Ursula vanonder derleyen
aurait laissé entendre que c'est la
Russie qui aurait bombarder Hiroshima
parce qu'elle aa de dire que ce sont les
États-Unis en réalité cette citation
elle est tronquée et oui van derlen ne
mentionne pas les États-Unis mais enfin
Hiroshima c'est un lieu commun son
propos est en fait de dire que alors que
le monde a connu la tragédie d'Hiroshima
il est inadmissible aujourd'hui que
quelqu'un comme le fait Vladimir Poutine
profère de nouveau des menaces
nucléaires c'est ça qu'elle a dit mais
sur la base de cet extrait l'émission
antifake prétend du même coup que les
Occidentaux réécrivent l'histoire y
compris aux yeux des Japonais
regardez ils ont déjà mentalement
dissocié les Japonais de leur propre
histoire et de leurs
ancêtres d'ailleurs nombreux sont ceux
qui justifient cette bombe car cela a
mis fin à la guerre alors que les
Américains ont génocidé les Japonais les
américains ils sont
finis les Américains sont finis on est
dans le registre de la feecte et du
jugement et non plus du tout de la lutte
contre les fakees d'ors d'ailleurs on
note au passage le logo de cette
émission dont l'esthétique rappelle les
caricature antisémite des années 40
alors qu'il semble cette fois figurer
l'Oncle Sam on le voit ici ils ont
mentalement dissocié les Japonais de
leur histoire nous dit ce blogueur
militaire russe en parlant des
États-Unis alors même si on analyse du
point de vue rationnel ce qu'il dit
c'est faux parce que un questionnaire
mené dans la rue japonaise par cette
même émission montre que les Japonais
savent parfaitement ce qu'était la trag
agédie de Hiroshima et qu'ils savent
parfaitement que cette bombe atomique
elle était américaine pour résumer
l'mission antifake elle prend pour
prétexte l'omission de cette mention des
États-Unis dans le bombardement de
Hiroshima par la présidente de la
Commission européenne pour prétendre un
que vaner lyen aurait accuser la Russie
du bombardement de Hiroshima de que les
Américains auraient réécrit leur
histoire aux yeux des Japonais et 3 que
le tout et bien aurait été à
l'initiative d'un centre ukrainien de
l'armée ukrainienne donc ce n'est pas du
tout un Antifit qu'on est plus dans un
complot oui et c'est un complot qui est
appuyé par le sommet de l'État russe
dans la même émission la porte-parole du
ministère russe des Affaires étrangères
Maria zacharova elle prétend que ce
n'est pas Vladimir Poutine qui agite en
menant en permanence la menace nucléaire
mais l'Occident sa théorie c'est que les
propos russes seraient systématiquement
tronqués par les médias occidentaux
regardez ils agitent sans cesse ce thème
comme quoi la Russie ne va pas tarder à
mener une frappe nucléaire et ensuite
alors que la Russie réagit par des
commentaires à ces déclarations ils
enlèvent les matériaux qui ont servi de
base à ces déclarations et il ne diffuse
à l'auditoire de masse que l'audio et la
vidéo de la réponse de la partie russe
sans indiquer qu'il s'agissait d'une
réponse il ne tiennent que grâce à ca
ils n'ont pas d'autes raison d'être
seulle la russophobie sert de matériaux
de cohésion à
l'ut ils n'ont rien
d'autre ce que dit Maria zacharova pour
dénoncer un prétendu fake occidental est
un fake pas plus tard qu'hier Vladimir
Poutine a de nouveau agité la menace
nucléaire et son propos n'était pas une
réponse à une quelconque déclaration
occidentale c'est la télévision russe et
non pas une chaîne occidentale comme
France 24 qui a diffusé ses propos sans
un contexte qu'elle aurait omis
d'ailleurs ces propos ils ont même fait
les titre du principal journal télévisé
du soir sur cette même chaîne russe P
canal qui diffuse antifake regardez
comment la Russie renforce-elle son
bouclier dans un monde en
turbulence nous av terminé les travx sur
le S Miss super lour nous allons bientô
le produire en me et le déployer nous
AVI termin les travx sur de nouau typ d'
mod nous avons avec succès un dernier t
sur de croisère àulsion nuéaire
Dei
la Russie dans sa course au réarmement
nucléaire possède donc deux nouveaux
types de missiles le sarmat un missile
balistique intercontinental de 200
tonnes capable selon le kremmelin de
déjouer tous les systèmes de défense
antiaérien moderne et de transporter
jusqu'à 10 ogives nucléaires et le
bourré vesnque a un missile à propulsion
nucléaire c'est-à-dire qu'il peut voler
très longtemps et atteindre n'importe
quelle partie du globe il peut
transporter des bombes conventionnelles
comme des bombes atomiques en 2018
Poutine disait qu'avec de telles armes
tous ceux qui je cite attaqueront la
Russie crèveront instantanément et alors
qu'il accuse désormais en permanence les
Occidentaux d'attaquer la Russie on peut
difficilement ne pas entendre dans ces
propos des menaces permanentes
d'employer l'arme nucléaire
pardonnez-moi et 3 jours après Ursula
van derl c'est Anthony blinken qui a
fait les frais de l'émission antiake
regardez nous avons surpris le
secrétaire d'État américain en plein
mensonge voilà ce qu'écrit ce personnage
il y a 82 ans les nazis ont massacr
34000 juifs à babiar les pouvoirs
soviétiques ont enterré cette histoire
que le gouvernement de Poutine manipule
aujourd'hui pour couvrir les abus russes
en Ukraine alors cette fois
effectivement ce que dit Anthony blinken
est inexact l'histoire du massacre de
babillard lorsque les nazis ont fusillé
près de 34000 Juifs en Ukraine elle n'a
pas été occultée en l'Union soviétique
comme il le dit en revanche en URSS on
parlait non pas de l'Holocauste mais du
CRIM nazi contre le peuple soviétique en
général mais il y a aussi du vrai dans
ce que dit blinken c'est qu'aujourd'hui
Vladimir Poutine instrumentalise bien la
guerre contre l'Allemagne naaszi pour
justifier sa propre guerre en Ukraine et
l'épisode de babillard survenu donc en
Ukraine il lui sert à fonder sur propos
sur une Ukraine prétendument toujours
nazie aujourd'hui cet été au Forum
économique de Saint-Pétersbourg il a
même diffusé un film d'archive sur le
massacre de babillard ou plutôt sur
l'occupation nazi de l'Ukraine y compris
le massacre de babillard pour appuyer
son propos lors de la session pliniiaère
et ce film il a été critiqué par les
historiens du mémorial de babillya
eux-même comme étant je cite une série
de mensonges et de fait détournés du
côté de l'émission antifake l'expert
invité à s'exprimer sur ce que dit
Anthony blinken c'est un blogueur
américain temporairement installé à
Moscou et invité sur les plateaux de
télévision russes écouter ce qu'il
dit blinken veut se débarrasser
totalement de la civilisation russe aux
États-Unis nombreux sont ceux qui sont
étonnés de voir
cela parce que la victoire contre
l'Allemagne Nazi était un exploit
colossal de l'armée soviétique et c'est
ce même exploit que sont en train
d'accomplir les soldats russes en
Ukraine en défendant le donbas du
nazisme et du gouvernement de
zelensk j'ai fait quelques recherche sur
ce blogueur américain que l'émission
antifake présente comme populaire il
s'appelle Jackson Hinkel il a 21 ans il
s'est brièvement essayé à une carrière
d'acteur mais il semble peu connu aux
États-Unis tout juste a-t-il été invité
sur la chaîne américaine Fox News dans
l'émission de Tucker Carlson connu pour
ses positions proorusses Hinkel s'est vu
décerner un prix journalistique par une
organisation américaine connue aussi
pour soutenir le régime du dictateur
syrien Bachar al-Assad il est
aujourd'hui fiancé non pas Bachar
al-Assad mais Hinkel à Miss Russie 2022
ce qu'on retient surtout hein c'est que
sous couvert de dévoiler des fakes
occidentaux l'émission russe antiake
propage le mythe de Vladimir Poutine sur
la dénazification de l'Ukraine oui tout
le contenu de cette émission est des
médias aut en Russie n'a qu'un but
produire davantage en fait de
désinformation à partir de contenu
parfois faux ou erroné mais parfois
aussi complètement détourné on l'a vu
avec le propos d'Ursula van derlen
antifake avalise le propos de la Russie
qui est de dire que la guerre d'Ukraine
n'est pas une guerre d'agression mais
une nouvelle guerre contre le nazisme
c'est-à-dire une guerre dans laquelle la
Russie aurait le bon
rôle merci beaucoup Elena c'est tout
pour vu de Russie